well today we want to learn a little bit
more about the red planet so we've
invited a geologist from the German
Aerospace Center to tell us a little bit
more goodra cooler thank you so much for
joining us here at tomorrow today now at
first let's pick up from where the
report left off and we've just learned
that Mars used to be a lot warmer
certainly above freezing on the surface
and that there was perhaps you know
liquid water there what does this tell
us now how did it change why did that
happen well what what we see is that has
been a dramatic change in the climate of
Mars but it was about 3.5 to 4 billion
years ago so we don't know exactly how
this worked and what the reason for that
was but it was aware it's very obvious
that before this change of climate we
had much more favorable conditions for
life so there's a slight chance that
life had existed there and after that it
was very hostile it was acidic and it
was not really wonderful like on earth
how would you compare the weather as
such on Mars in comparison to here on
earth is there a comparison turtle of
course you can compare it and the
biggest difference is it never rains in
Martha okay so there's no snippet ation
normal there's no precipitation at all
and it's very cold it's a very thin
atmosphere and it's a different
atmosphere from Earth its carbon dioxide
and it's not no oxygen no nitrogen very
little nitrogen and so it's a very
hostile atmosphere for photosynthesis
okay so um but in other words is there
any other similarities that we could
draw between Mars and Earth how else are
we alike there has been a lot of
similarities at least in the early time
of past since we see the traces of water
running over the surface there are
riverbeds they're big channels and they
had been glaciers there are polar caps
with eyes so there are similarities so
we talked about that mass is the most
similar planet to earth in the solar
system now NASA's Curiosity robots is
currently collecting soil samples and
finding out new evidence what's the
latest there and what's what's
interesting about it that they have
found well that's really a big story a
very successful story they have selected
a very good landing side it has
the Creator that was filled with water
once and on the bed of this lake there
was the sediments deposited and these
sediments obviously have been in a water
standing body of water with very neutral
chemistry it was not acid it was not
alkaline so it was really good favorable
for life may be favorable for life
that's the key question I suppose now
can you tell us a little bit about Mars
Express and what you've had to do with
that a mass expresses the European
mission observing mass since almost ten
years and we have made made big regional
surveys of the area and checked out for
the traces of waters to get more
information about a climatic history of
this planet and several Mars missions
are being planned at the moment if there
was one outcome that you would really
like to see out of one of these missions
what might it be well I hope that I will
ever have the chance to investigate a
sample from mass here on earth so the
big thing would be in a next decade or
so to return samples with an automated
mission with a robotic mission from mass
to our laboratories here that are much
bigger and could do all these
investigations for traces of life and
you could not do on the surface of Mars
picasa t laboratories are too big too
expensive and finally a water is out
there on Mars temperatures were moderate
in the past so what are the chances that
there was actually like there well i
would say that there are slight chances
that in the early times of mars life
might have existed on the planet and
chances today are much slimmer a
recorder thank you so much for joining
us here at tomorrow's day